Customs and Border Patrol agents are
pushing back against criticism after a
government watchdog report showed how
detention facilities along the southern
border are in turmoil President Trump
tweeted yesterday quote if illegal
immigrants are unhappy with the
conditions just tell them not to come
sounds like a policy of deterrence there
Mireya Villarreal spoke exclusively with
one border agent she's in the Rio Grande
Valley in South Texas
Maria what did this agent say this
veteran agent told us that CBP has been
warning Congress about the humanitarian
crisis and the conditions inside these
facilities for months and this new OIG
report should be no surprise to anyone
we have blurred his face and also
altered his voice to conceal his
identity has to be a solution this
Border Patrol agent told us he feels
compassion for the migrants in his
custody but he his co-workers and even
his family are being treated and
portrayed unfairly on Tuesday the Office
of Inspector General released an
explosive report detailing severe
overcrowding and issues at CBP
facilities investigators described
children with no access to showers or
hot meals and adults being held in
standing-room-only conditions for a week
with showers we're not built with
kitchenettes to where we can have a warm
meal for these individuals it's far
worse than anything I have ever seen
anywhere
Lisa Brady Agha has been an immigration
attorney for more than 40 years she
recently filed a lawsuit in Texas
against the government demanding relief
for her migrant clients who are being
held in CBP custody they don't have
decent food they don't have drinkable
water now they're being told to drink
out of toilets before we were told that
they were the water that they were given
was so heavily chlorinated that it made
people sick to drink
that's torture we asked the agent to
describe what it's like inside the
facility where he works it gets quite
and simultaneously you get hit with the
smell of what of people that have been
there for too long people that do need a
shop but how do I give it to them where
do I take them with what budget I don't
have that possibility
I just told earlier this week the
President signed a four point six
billion dollar humanitarian aid package
that would hopefully help with the
facility conditions but the agents that
we're talking to here on the ground in
South Texas tell us it feels like this
is a little too little too late and this
should have been addressed months ago
the agent that I spoke with in the
shadows also says that the old
immigration laws need to be the target
here not the Border Patrol agents in the
field Maria thank you it's interesting
but if there's really bipartisan
agreement that this is among other
things a humanitarian crisis and that's
where that money is supposed to go Maria
thank you very much hopefully people
will believe an agent who's actually
working inside the facility they will
believe what he has to say because
they've called into question what the
people who are living there and what
some of the congressional people have
said but this is somebody who works
their day to day hopefully his story
somebody will believe this president
tweet it seems to acknowledge the
conditions aren't good very very
complicated